The next step in our plan is to check
the text that we've read thus far for profanity. Now,
to do this, I searched the Internet and found
this website called wdyl.com or what do you love. This
website was developed by Google and one of the
things it does is that it can tell us if
a word is a curse word or not. So,
if I go to this website's profanity link, which is
profanity question mark q, by the way, this
link is also available in the instructor notes
and try out the word shot, S-H-O-T and
see what happens. ha, the website's response is false
which means that this word, the word shot, is not a curse word. But if I
change this word by just one letter and
hit Enter. The response is a little bit different.
I can even give this website a sentence or a paragraph. So let me, in place of
saying one word, say, I can take a shot at it and hit
Enter, and the response is false, which means that this sentence is fine. But,
if I change one word in that sentence, so I will say, I can, well, you know,
and then hit Enter. Ooh, the response now is
true, which means that there is a curse word
in this sentence. [SOUND] All we have to do
now is do what we've been doing, but using code.